很帅的时候啊，
我是自己当了妈妈之后，
我才发现这个世界上有一些父母的爱是有条件的，
有一些父母的爱是无条件的，
而有条件的居多，
无条件的居少，
像你的这样的情况是居多的，
就父母对你的爱可能是有条件的，
你必须有出息，
你能挣钱，
你能给他们长脸，
你能给他们养老，
只有一小部分人对孩子的爱是无条件的，
我是92年的，
目前是人未婚，
原生家庭的问题呢，
是一直困扰着我，
尤其是最近发生了很多事情，
但我就是这个西鞋一直打不开。
小的时候呢，
我的原生家庭条件不是特别好，
我基本上穿的都是别人的旧衣服，
比如说像学校里面老师会推荐我参加一些表演出啊，
都是老师帮我去别的同学借一些旧衣服穿，
所以我从小会有点自卑，
在这样的一个情况下呢，
我的母亲当别人给我买一套新衣服的时候，
会逼着我把这套新衣服给我的姐姐穿，
也就是我舅舅家的女儿，
其实这个事情呢，
一直在我心里面就是过不去，
但是我没有办法跟他去说一说，
他就第二个事情呢，
就是我小的时候呢，
喜欢攒钱，
我的钱也被那个姐姐偷掉了，
他也不允许我说。
第3个事情呢，
在前几年的时候。
哦，
我基本上常年是不在家的，
因为我没有办法跟他们就是长时间相处啊，
有一年生病了，
我回来一直照顾他，
他出院之后呢，
给家里转了1万块钱，
我强调他不要喝酒，
他不听，
他说你不要说话，
结果第二天他有很严重的病又复发，
又要住院了，
这一次我就很生气，
我就没有再去很认真的去照顾他，
这个事情结束之后，
吵架的时候，
他就会怪我说，
他说我永远记得你，
我生病的时候你没有管我怎么样子，
穿插一下，
我是2023年底的时候回家的，
我在家差不多待了两年，
其实之前一直都是在外面，
在三月份的时候呢，
我的舅妈就是我刚刚一直提到我的那个姐姐的那妈妈，
我一直都不是特别喜欢我的舅妈跟舅舅，
那个舅妈呢，
要介绍一个男孩，
就是让我相亲，
但是我说我不想相亲，
我不想结婚，
他说那个男孩儿什么条件怎么怎么好，
在哪里有房子，
他说人家特意回来一趟来见你，
跟这个男生认识了之后一段时间，
我发现他们所说的很多事情全都是谎言，
包括什么特地来见我，
其实是跟别的人相亲，
没有相上，
然后来见我的，
其次这个男孩子呢，
也没有什么房子，
也没有他们所说的那些好的工作。
然后有一个重要的事情是跟这个男。
生相处的过程当中呢，
他有一次出差，
让我去到他那边，
我自己订了机票之后，
我说你住的酒店发给我，
我自己来订房间，
他强调要求我说不行，
让我跟他住一个房间，
我立马说我机票退了，
我不去了，
自此之后呢，
我就不跟他联系了，
因为这个是舅妈认识的双方呢，
其实亲人其实也一直在默默关注这个事情嘛，
但是我不想跟家里面过多讲这个事情，
如果我舅妈知道我跟这个男孩子分开了之后，
我妈妈来问我这个事情了，
我就把里面很多谎言，
包括这个男孩子要求我跟他住一个房间这个事情，
我妈妈的反应是他全程跟我吵架，
包括她瞪着眼睛跟我说，
你为什么不能跟他在一起，
以上的这些行为呢，
就是我一直都无法理解为什么母亲会这样对我的，
这是我的一个心里的困惑，
也是我一直的一个心结，
接下来讲一下父亲，
我的父亲呢，
类似于可能是您所说的NPD的一个性格，
他是家里面最小的一个，
特别要面子，
他对外面的人特别好，
他总是口头上我要做那什么大生意啊什么的，
但是他其实一个月的话差不多也就挣个两三千块钱，
他在外面就要表现的他很厉害，
他很强。
但是回到。
他永远都是斜着眼睛看家里面人发脾气，
就是在我的心里面，
我觉得他像一个魔鬼，
每一次呢，
我跟他们去说任何问题的时候，
他就会用道德来绑架我，
就是比如说我们是父母，
怎么会对你不好呢？
你再这样子给你跪下来，
你还要我怎么样？
在我2023年回来之后呢，
其实我在家里面赚钱会比在外面稍微好一点，
我手头呢，
会稍微的宽松一点，
之后呢，
在2024年的时候，
我决定在我的父母去北京玩一趟，
我想让我这个家庭好一些，
但是在北京的时候，
大马路上我妈撒泼了，
我爸呢对着我说，
你到底要我们怎么样，
我给你跪大马路上像撒泼似的在那儿吵架，
北京人当时在那儿说，
他说你们不要这样，
这是北京，
最后来讲一下我自己，
我觉得我的能力能量不是特别强的一个人，
所以这几个月呢，
我一直都是在家里面，
要么出去逛逛街，
要么在家里面进行看书，
做自己的工作，
我不跟父母在接触了，
我跟父母已经隔有几个月没有再联系了，
我现在内心呢，
会比较平静一些，
有能量一些，
但是我本人的道德感有点过强，
我总觉得我要去好好的孝顺父母，
我不。
再去忤逆他们，
没有办法去跟他们切断，
没有啊，
我不知道你的父母是什么风格，
但我知道人就是千差万别的，
这个世界上10个人里头有一个人，
你是永远不要寄希望于在他那里你能得到真正的爱，
因为有些人他不去备爱别人的能力，
有些人他连他爱他自己都不会。
你要问我有没有一种可能去跟原生家庭去和解，
跟他们关系能处的很好，
有一种可能性就是你修为特别高，
你修到那种不再把他们当父母，
把他们当成儿女，
把他们当成小朋友一样的，
把他们当成一个怜悯众生的角色，
那有可能关系处的好，
但是我们普通人是很难修到那样的修为的，
把父母当儿女看，
把父母当芸芸众生看，
对众生产生怜悯之心看，
然后你不再去计较他们是否爱你，
不再去想要从他们身上获得爱，
反过来你已经能量完全的大于他们了，
完全是俯视的角度，
才有可能和经营好这种关系。
其实那个时候也不叫经营了，
那个时候就是俯视，
在怜悯心，
在慈悲心，
因为他们也不曾得到过他的父母的爱，
所以他们也不懂得怎么爱我。
你要是说修到这种境界的话，
才有可能跟你的父母关系处好，
否则的话是处不好的，
绝大部分人是修不到那种修为的。
把父母当儿女看，
理解父母他们也不懂得，
他们也不曾被真正爱过，
所以他们怎么可能会真正的爱我，
我只好做好我这一世的功课，
如果我心中有爱，
我可以分他们一点，
如果我心里面没有修来这些爱的话，
那我就离得远一点，
毕竟你刚刚说到修到把父母当成小孩子看，
其实呢，
因为原生家庭这个问题呢，
我这两年也一直都爱看这方面的书嘛，
他会让我们去孝敬父母，
就是我内心里面就会很纠结，
我到底该怎么做？
我跟你讲，
姐妹，
以我对你现在的判断的话，
我认为你还没有到那样的修为，
你做不到，
不要勉强自己，
离得远一点也没关系，
为什么说要离得远一点？
我给你讲一个概念，
就是很多宇航员他离开地球了之后，
从宇宙来看待地球，
从此之后，
他再从宇宙回到地球的时候，
他真的就心情没有什么波动啊，
为了争地盘打得头破血流的，
什么公司和公司合伙人之间为了这一点利益搞得阴谋背叛的，
什么夫妻之间因为什么矛盾打得不可开交的，
从宇宙回来的宇航员眼里的话已经不具备任何的意义了，
他的情绪不会被这些事情所牵动了，
那对于你来说的话，
就离开父母，
离得远一点，
从遥远的方向去看待他们的时候，
当有一天。
你真的能修到那种把父母当儿女看，
甚至把父母当小猫小狗看，
我这里的小猫小狗没有贬低的意思啊，
就纯属说你对他们产生一种悲悯之心，
你不再计较的时候，
你才有可能回来关起处好啊，
我现在非常清楚我不适合跟他们在一起，
我也想着离开他们不要独立，
那你对我未来的一个就是个人的发展有没有什么建议，
包括说其实我之前有出去独立过，
但是他们会用各种各样的方法，
比如说他会找我身边的亲戚，
甚至以前会找我的朋友来，
各种的去影响我的生活，
你要有屏蔽力，
屏蔽力是什么意思呢？
该赦免打扰就赦免打扰，
不想接的电话可以不接的，
所有的姐妹们啊，
不要形成一种非常好的素质，
来的电话你都接，
就是不想接的电话是可以不接的，
不想回的消息是可以不回的，
你只要把你自己的工作做好了，
工作上该回的消息，
工作上该接的电话不要漏接之外，
其他所有的电话不想接是可以不接的，
消息也是不想回是可以不回的。
不要太有素质，
错，
其实并不是很爱我是吗？
坦率的说啊，
我是自己当了妈妈之后，
我才发现这个世界上有一些父母的爱是有条件的，
有一些父母的爱是无条件的，
而有条件的居多，
无条件的去少。
像你的这样的情况是居多的，
就父母对你的爱可能是有条件的，
你必须有出息，
你能挣钱，
你能给他们长脸，
你能给他们养老，
只有一小部分人对孩子的爱是无条件的，
我懂了，
我的工作呢，
是属于独立的工作，
导师比较自由一些，
我可以离开这个城市，
就是您对我未来的一个人发展有没有什么，
就是根据您现在的一些，
你走过来的一些经验，
给我到一些进遇，
嗯，
如果你是做老师的，
那么对于你来说，
你的客户资源，
你跟学生之间的关系，
包括跟学生家长之间的关系，
你要为你自己的拓展嘛，
学会去经营你的回头客，
去经营你的这些贵人圈，
这人际关系，
你才有更多的信任度，
更多的这个学生生源资源感好，
谢谢你，
罗菲姐，
希望你越来越好，
谢谢你啊，
如果说我们普通老百姓，
我们也不可能像宇航员那样有这样的机会说飞到太空当中去，
去感受一下，
那我有一个建议给到大家，
大家可以趁着飞机票比较便宜的时候，
那就是200块钱也能买一张飞机票，
解不开的扣的，
心里面有很多愤懑的朋友，
飞一趟，
因为我是有这种感受，
当飞机从地面一点一点往上升，
一点一点往上升的时候，
对，
城市里面就这么一格一格的小水泥房子里，
你看到的。
是千家万户，
整个城市里面都发生着一些爱恨相关的这些纠葛，
你会有不一样的心境，
你会觉得没有什么过不去的坎儿。
我们都是蝼蚁，
我们这一辈子的所有的爱恨情仇，
狗屁都不是，
谁能懂我这个点？
真的，
我们这辈子谁背叛了我，
谁伤害了我，
谁恨过我，
谁爱过我，
狗屁都不是。
记得点赞关注哦。